say Iran and what comes to mind
ayatollahs crowds chanting death to
America death to Britain missiles
hostages terrorism let's face it that is
the country's image in the West but it's
a huge complex place with connections
everywhere there's a lot more to Iran
than that how big a threat is it and how
much is our view down to propaganda how
dangerous is Iran really to answer that
question we have to ask another how
dangerous do they think we are they call
Britain little Satan an America Great
Satan and to some extent you can see why
their history is one long sorry tale of
Western interference we repeatedly
carved up their territory the British
tried to take over their oil the CIA and
Britain top of one of their elected
leaders and supported Iraq in the war in
the 80s that killed millions so should
be all that surprising if Iranians don't
trust us much and fear the West is
looking for regime change the objectives
of the regime are not going to change
and therefore the only solution is to
change the regime itself if the
leadership of Iran behaves badly then
it's gonna be a very very bad day for
them Iran is an authoritarian theocratic
state that means it's run by religious
people under religious laws except that
and you can live your life and in some
ways it looks like many where else but
if you don't agree with the rules it can
be very dangerous indeed dissenters who
openly criticize the way around is run
or in danger of arrest torture
disappearing in jail so a women who
don't like the religious rule they have
to wear a headscarf many have been
rounded up and not seen since and
protesting against the rule LGBT people
are in grave danger to gay sex is
illegal and punishable by death
thousands have been executed for loving
a member of their own sex states like
these and their terrorist allies
constitute an axis of evil arming to
threaten the peace of the world but how
evil and how dangerous you think Iran is
depends probably on who you are and
where for the most to fear probably
Israel Iranian leaders have talked about
wiping Israelis off the face of the
earth I'll be reassuring and Israel
accuses Iran of working around the clock
to come up with a way of doing so a red
line should be drawn right here before
Iran completes the second stage of
nuclear enrichment then there are Iran's
Arab neighbors who had divided Rhonda
Shear so sheer Muslims in Syria Yemen's
southern Lebanon Germany sirenians as
allies Sunni Muslims in Egypt the Gulf
states and most of all Saudi Arabia do
not they accuse Iran of attacking them
and plotting against them what about the
West well this is Washington's rap sheet
on Iran first its accused of spreading
terrorism around the world supporting
groups like the Houthis in Yemen Hamas
in Gaza Hizballah in Lebanon secondly it
wants to build the nuclear bomb says the
US and the means of delivering it Iran
has developed an armory of missiles
could now reach the heart of Europe
despite all that though the west and
Iran had a go at burying the hatchet
under Barack Obama the u.s. tried a new
tack led by America the big cows in Iran
tried to do a deal the plan was to focus
just on Iran's alleged bomb-making and
give them a pass and all that alleged
terrorism and missile making it works
after five painful years of negotiations
Iran opened up to inspections to prove
it wasn't making the bomb and sanctions
were lifted and then Donald Trump got
elected he hated the deal never ever
ever in my life have I seen any
transaction so incompetently negotiated
as our deal with Iran and even though it
had been signed in good faith he ripped
up America's signature on it and went
back on all its commitments
and America says Iran can't be trusted
Iran's government's is complicated at
the top the supreme leader below him the
elected politicians president and
cabinet called the moderates then there
are the hardliners the military the
Islamic Revolutionary Guard Corps and
other shadowy security agencies they
hold each other in check
Barack Obama hope the nuclear deal would
help the moderates and make Iran less
dangerous now the deal is falling apart
and the hardliners are getting more
powerful so the situation is only
looking more dangerous
you